رمضان اهلا بك ومساء الخير مرحبا رمضان
بدايه ما هي الاسلحه التي وعدت بريطانيا
بارسالها الى اوكرانيا للاشارات سبق
لفرنسا للولايات المتحده وللمانيا ان
اعلنت نيتها ارسال اليات قتاليه خفيفه
لدعم الجيش الاوكراني الجديد مع بريطانيا
والتوجه الى تزويد الجيش الاوكراني باسلحه
نوعيه 14
دبابه قتاليه ثقيله من تراث تشالنجر اثنين
بالاضافه الى 30 مدفع عن ذاتيه الدفع من
طراز اي اس 90 وذلك وبذلك يسلك ريتشي
سوناك نفس خطاه سلفيه
دعم الجيش الاوكراني منذ بدايه النزاع في
العام 2022 بريطانيا كانت السباقه في
تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه النوعيه ومنها
مضادات دبابات محموله من طراز ان لو وكان
لها الفضل هذه الاسلحه في افتقدم الدبابات
والمدرعات الروسيه في بدايه
النزاع حول العاصمه اكياف بريطانيا هي
ثاني دوله بعد الولايات المتحده في دعم
اوكرانيا بالسلاح وذلك هو هذه هي الميزه
بالنسبه للوعود الاوكرانيه الجديده
بريطانيا اوكرانيا باسلحه ثقيله رمضان
ولماذا الان حتى الان ترددت الدول الغربيه
وفي طليعتها المانيا
بتزويد اوكرانيا بالسلاح الثقيل حتى لا
تساهم في انزلاق الحرب الى نزاع شامل ولكن
في ظل استراتيجيه القصف العشوائيه التي
تطال المدنيين ابدت عده دول في طلعتها
بريطانيا بولندا وفنلندا الاستعداد لتزويد
اوكرانيا بالسلاح الثقيل من الاشاره وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه تصدر يوميا منذ بدايه
الحرب نشره الاستخباراتيه حول سير المعارك
على الارض هذا الانتقال النوعي في الاسلحه
معناها ان البريطانيين يملكون معطيات تؤشر
على نقاط ضعف في الدفاعات الروسيه وان
تزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه الثقيله الان قد
يحسم المعركه لصالح الاوكرانيين الان
التخوف في الدول الغربيه هو الى اي مدى
يمكن مساعده الاوكرانيين من دون التحول
الى طرف في النزاع هذا السؤال الاجابه عنه
تحددها روسيا وكانت وكيف ستتعامل مع هذا
التطور للاشاره اعتبار بريطانيا ترف في
الحرب معناها ان الحرب تمتد لتصبح بين
روسيا وبين حلف شمال الاطلسي هذا
السيناريو التي تقول روسيا انه يحدث فعلا
الان